Did you know that Korea has the lowest total fertility rate in the world?
Actually it's not that big of a surprise.
The number of only children is growing rapidly,...
...and even worse, more and more married couples aren't willing to have any children.
I heard the lowest total fertility rate recorded so far was something like 1.17.
Why do you think such a social trend occurs?
I've never thought that as a major concern.
Come to think of it, now I realize that we should take some action.
As things stand, Korea will be losing a significant number of its population per year, don't you think?
Think about it, the number of newly born babies could continue to decline in the future...
...and the population growth will be forecasted to record a negative growth.
I guess it's happening because of the depressed economy,...
...unemployment and couples both having to work for a living.
So the government suggests new plans to encourage Korean women to make more babies,...
...including offering incentives, maternity and paternity support,...
...pension contributions, and other social welfare - related payments.
I hope the new rules imposed deliver positive consequences.
So do I.
I really hope the Korean government can solve this problem effectively.
Again, a low birth rate is a very serious problem not only in Korea but in many countries.
If the Korean government can solve this problem, the future of Korea will be very bright.
I think the human resource is the most crucial factor in our society.
Therefore, we should all try and do something together.